alter jetzt gehts hier gerade richtig ab
die finden mich einfach nicht die finden
mich nicht die sehen mich wirklich nicht
die gehen weg
er hat unheimlich brutal geschlagen
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einem kleinen
lara video auf dem hof im server ja ich
hab mich mal wieder dazu durchgedrungen
auf diesem server aufzunehmen ich hatte
daher oftmals ein paar probleme mit
dieser führungsetage auf dem server weil
das ganze weise nicht ist nicht so wie
mir das so gefällt also die leute sind
die leute denen es ist auch eine ganz
andere geschichte ich mag die leute dann
wenn ich die den server haben und das
finden sehr viele leute um die kümmern
sich um diesem server nahezu gar nicht
mehr und ich finde einfach die deutschen
server für sympathischer wie kommen und
so aber das ist eine ganz andere sache
ich wollte einfach ein kleines lager
video machen und dabei ein wenig anders
denn als sieger oder einen sieg spielen
jetzt einfach mal schauen welche lobby
wiederkommen wurde es gerade noch das
volk wir gehen
ich wollte etwas reden und zwar hate auf
youtube.com bump an der sache ich möchte
sich halo zelda a link ich möchte jetzt
nicht über etwas reden wie ich weiß
nicht fabio cxd
ich möchte jetzt nicht so sagen ja ich
hasse es dass ihr meine videos das laut
nein ich möchte etwas anderes reden und
wenn ihr nicht dafür bereit seid dass
ich jetzt quasi einfach ein bisschen mit
euch quatschen dann geht bitte dich voll
gehört und wenn ihr haltlos darauf habe
dass ich so ein bisschen aber gerade ich
versuche mich kurzzeitig hab grad das
schon mal in 20 minuten aufgenommen
sollen wir viel zu lang ist ein versuch
ist jetzt kürzer und die sache ist halt
ich möchte players waging porno business
startet ich möchte auf jeden fall schon
mal ein bisschen reden und saatgut und
zwar überall hält ich mag das aber nicht
so genau welche da noch wieso belästigt
man ja hallo ich möchte herrn stellt er
sich da einen ja cool so jedenfalls von
ok was soll das e mail drehen die runde
wird einfach genauso lang
hey kannst du bitte kämen
es geht los gut wir sind roth hatte was
von wurzeln wir also wurden ich glaube
der hektisch ging das ist erst mal kurz
verstecken gehen und danach möchte mit
euch reden hatte ich keine schon mal
anfangen alles wieder okay das ist nicht
so toll
ich verstecke jetzt einfach mal die
runderen älter ruckelt die auch wieder
so ein paar dinge die ich halt
ansprechen möchte ich jetzt einfach
nicht mehr direkt entdeckt das ist mir
egal ist nämlich meine art so es ist mir
egal wie gut ich irgendwie im pvp bin ob
ich jetzt verliere ob ich gewinne ob ich
jetzt als erster nein ich finde ich
nicht ob ich jetzt als erster geschlagen
werde ob ich als ob ich gewinne
das ist mir vollkommen egal das ist
meine art ich bin nicht gut im pvp ich
habe mich damit noch nie
auseinandergesetzt und es ist nicht das
worauf ich wert lege auf meinem kanal
nicht lege wert darauf dass ich selber
bin dass ich das machen wozu ich lust
habe und das so bearbeitet und so
schneide wie ich lust habe und so spiele
wie ich lust habe das gelände special
pack nehmen wozu ich lust habe dass sich
ein shader nehme man radio hat 0
war ja fakt jedenfalls was ich damit
sagen möchte ist ich bin ich selber und
das motto von youtube ist broadcast
yourself und broadcast yourself als
zunimmt das auf was du willst so in etwa
macht das was du willst du ich bin hier
nicht gebunden tv studio wer mir zurzeit
in den trends lassen das macht mal dazu
ein witz und den legen wir euch hier auf
regie zettel vor und das müsst ihr dann
sagen an der der minute nächstes so ich
mache das ganze selber ich mach das
alleine
ich bin nicht angewiesen ich bin nicht
darauf angewiesen dass sich youtube
mache also setzt nicht so dass ich sage
wenn ich diesen monaten nur zwei videos
mache dann verdiene ich nicht so viel
dass ich meine miete bezahlen kann ich
arbeite nebenbei ich bei fußball
nebenbei und die studieren nebenbei das
heißt die macht youtube nur so aus jux
und tollerei weil es mir spaß macht und
die sache ist dass viele leute zahlt
nicht akzeptieren
das heißt viele leute einige leute
akzeptieren das nicht es gibt immer noch
sehr viele leute unter euch zum beispiel
die jetzt gerade noch dran sind zum
beispiel wenn jetzt so getan seit wenn
ich wirklich einfach mobil woran man
quasi eigentlich nichts aussetzen kann
aber trotzdem schreiben die schon wieder
leute blöd bist du wieder nur redet
dieser fabio zeigt dass ein bisschen
aufdringlich call du möchtest nie im
leben entscheiden schritt wird die ganze
zeit auch so contractor finde mich oder
ich finde dich gleich schreibt da bist
du noch da bestimmt
sowas ist voll witzig mir die sache ist
dass ich quasi das machen möchte das was
ich liebe und es ist quasi youtube und
viele leute schreiben mir unter defekts
folgen beispielsweise nehme ich mal die
facts folge als beispiel
ich habe ja seit ein paar monaten dieses
geheimnisvolle geräusche das heißt ich
nehmen beispielsweise hier mein
portemonnaie mache so zeigen natürlich
das nicht in der fei scam allerdings
sage ich dann okay leute wenn ihr jetzt
bock habt könnt ihr das in die
kommentare schreiben das erraten und
dann eher wenig eventuell in der
nächsten folge
das habe ich so eingeführt weil ich
darauf bock habe weil ich lust habe
irgendwelche geräusche zu zeigen einfach
zu sehen ob ihr das erraten könnte oder
nicht und einfach eure kanäle so ein
bisschen zu pushen also wenn da zum
beispiel in den kanal schreibt und er
sich ganz viele gedanken macht so jo was
ist das wenn ihr euch und bei
dann selber denkt okay wenn er dann
wirklich dass er rate und er nimmt einen
kommentar event ul dran geht mein
kommentar in seinem video eingeblendet
dadurch gehen vielleicht ein paar leute
offenen kanal blabla das ist der grund
warum ich das gemacht habe ich meine ich
verdienen ja kein geld daran dass ihr
das geräusch erwartet das ist einfach
das was mir spaß macht und dann
schreiben da leute darunter du [ __ ]
das infekts folgen warum macht zulagen
geräusch da denke ich mir so jo des main
kanal das ist mal ein effekt serie und
die kann ich aufbauen wie ich möchte ich
könnte auch einfach sagen ich hab keine
lust noch hektisch lasse sein
das könnte theoretisch auch sagen das
heißt nur weil er jetzt jemand sagt es
ist voll kacke das drüben geräusch macht
man mal auf damit heißt ja nicht dass
ich das mache allerdings bin ich immer
noch damals so gewesen
vor einer woche oder so bevor ich mir
also und gedanken zu gemacht habe wie
von diesem video war ich so jo ok
er will kein geräusch ich mache meine
umfrage hab da eine umfrage gemacht so
solidarisch wie ich halt bin wo er war
jemand möchte dass es quasi allen
gefällt und er hat eine umfrage gemacht
und da kann man daraus das irgendwie so
und so viele leute wollten das geräusch
weiterhin und so und so viele leute
waren dagegen
allerdings waren mehr leute dafür als
dagegen die 60 zu 40 prozent also
relativ ausgeglichene sache aber die
leute dieses geräusch wollten gewonnen
dann hab ich gesagt mach jetzt in jeder
folge weiter an das geräusch und dann
kamen leute an die meinten junge also
wirklich in dem wortlaut junge du machst
ja schon wieder das geheimnisvolle
geräusche
ich gebe jetzt einen dislike auf jedes
video das ist mein neues hobby genauen
wortlaut ich will diesen typen die
person nicht erwähnen allerdings sind
solche leute für mich ganz ganz
schlechte menschen sage ich mal
weil ich gehe schon extra auf diese
leute zu und sage diesen leuten ja wenn
ihr das geheimnisvolle geräusche nicht
wollt ich habe extra wegen euch nur
umfrage gemacht dann stimmt da auch für
nein ab und sagt euren freunden
eventuell das ist nicht so sein soll
ich verdiene nichts an der umfrage auch
nichts an ganz von geräusche so etwas
was mir spaß macht und die umfrage mache
ich weil ich will dass es auch spaß
macht und hab das ganze macht und dann
meckern halt trotz noch leute rum
ich hab das mittlerweile so geregelt
dass die dienstags das geräusch mache
und freitags halt nicht einmal zwei
folgen pro woche immer kommen kommt ja
auch noch mal einer
oder wenn ich das ganze jetzt und die
sache ist halt dass ich noch nicht weiß
wie das ganz ankommen weil ich das jetzt
zum ersten mal so gemacht hat eine woche
aber bestimmt kommen trotzdem noch leute
am dienstag an und meinen dann warum
machst du das kleinste geräusch ich
möchte aber nicht so mit euch meckern
sondern ich möchte quasi nicht auch
nicht einen deal anbieten sondern
einfach dass wir so ein bisschen
vertragen auch so ein bisschen uns
vertragen
der vertrag ist es halt auch nicht
sondern es ist halt wirklich einfach so
ich möchte halt dass das ganze gesittet
abläuft in den kommentaren ich habe zum
beispiel auch gelesen
letztens schreiben das schreiben immer
sehr viele leute höre ich bin erster
oder irgend sowas
das ist natürlich auch nicht so cool ich
fand das mal cool wenn man erster
schalte ich mir gedacht habe okay man
sollte sich schon toll fühlen wenn man
erster ist ein video von einem großen
youtube beispielsweise die sagt das aber
mittlerweile nur noch weil man selber
eigentlich kommentare sind dazu da um
das video zu kommentieren und nicht so
etwas zu schreiben die erster oder höhe
kommt main kanal an oder werbung und
also das ist zum beispiel der grund
warum die preise einen kanal geschlossen
hat ach sein kann als ein wenig
behindert der seine youtube kommentare
ausgestellt hat weil da die ganze zeit
in dieser fabio zocken nicht ein wenig
auf
alter gut
der hat als seine kommentare auch
zugemacht so macht geschlossen also
ausgestellt weil da halt nur noch spam
beleidigungen und werbung ankam und das
ist bei mir halt auch so ich lese mal so
schaut auf einem kanal vorbei das finde
ich nicht schlimm
das finde ich nicht so schlimm was ich
allerdings schwimmen finde ist wenn
jemand beleidigungen schreibt also ich
sehe leute die schreiben ihnen so was
wie erster was ja schon nicht so cool
ist aber was mache und cooler ist es
wenn man dann schreib deine mutter du
[ __ ] so das schreiben so viele
leute und da denke ich mir mal so ey
leute vielleicht ist seine mutter tot
und dann wird er durch euren kommentar
irgendwie daran erinnert und ich finde
das total traurig wenn man so beschreibt
es ein ganz ganz schlechte menschen für
mich ich mag das gar nicht und ich
möchte halt so ein bisschen dass wir da
so ein bisschen wieder ruhe in die szene
rein bekommen und wenn ihr da lust an
habt dann oder auch davon überzeugt seid
dann schreibt einfach mal positiven
kommentar voller energie in die
kommentare was ihr von diesem ganzen
thema halte die sache ist halt es das
geht mich halt relativ viel an weil ich
lag da beispielsweise ein video hoch von
der mod von der watchdog smart wo ich
mir denkt okay das ist eine coole mode
und ich feiere dieser mode und ich denke
die könnt ihr euch aufgefallen und
deswegen da dies hoch aber dann sehe ich
da drunter kommentare das passt zu mir
hier sehe ich da drunter kommentare wie
beispielsweise hier kann ich da oben hin
möchte doch stehen es ist der vom
blumentopf woanders hin
das ist ein neues versteck und dann lese
ich darunter allerdings kommentare wie
beispielsweise was soll das denn wieso
stellst du dir niemand vor du hast die
von schlecht vorgestellt bei den local
minecraft immer und so was alles und die
sache derzeit ist es natürlich
gerechtfertigte kritik allerdings ich
versuche auf euch zuzugehen ich versuche
mal zu machen die euch gefallen
ich versuche beispielsweise auch ich
wollen wir beim neuen pc
höchstwahrscheinlich an alles klappen
sollte dann ist er in ein paar wochen
hier und dann sollte das ganze endlich
auch mal funktionieren mit dem ruckeln
und alles möglich allerdings wie halt
schon am anfang gesagt ich mach das
ganze aus spaß zur leidenschaft weil ich
lust habe und ich möchte mir da nicht
durch irgendwelche leute was
vorschreiben lassen und ich möchte auch
und das ist die hauptbotschaft in diesem
video broadcast yourself
das heißt ich lade das hoch was ich
möchte wann ich möchte ich könnte auch
einfach sagen ihr euch auch mit effect
serie und dann werden halt auch ganz
viele leute rummeckern ich weiß dass
eine gewisse verantwortung gegenüber
euch habe also da sind relativ viele
zuschauer die erwarten regelmäßige
videos allerdings bin ich eine
einzelperson ich mache das alleine
ich habe kein team das hinter mir steht
ich hab keinen macht es halt nicht
hauptberuflich welches hauptberuflich
machen würde wäre etwas anderes dann
müsste ich quasi sagen okay ihr bekommt
die idealen 234 videos blabla weil ich
den ganzen tag mit youtube beschäftigten
aber so ist halt nicht ich gehe halt
studieren ich mache sport noch nebenbei
ich mal ganz ganz viele sachen und
youtube kommt da nicht zu kurz ich denke
ich habe das ganz gut alles unter einem
hut aber die sache ist halt dass viele
leute halt einfach um meckern und das
mag ich halt nicht so also ich finde
dass man man kann ruhig pose
konstruktive kritik ist jetzt meine
hände mal wieder hier aus rosenheim hat
spaß
der sieht uns echt nicht ich dachte nie
dass meine hin kommen könnte gerade
entdeckt da entdeckt
da ein ja ich weiß nicht was ich noch
sagen soll also diese haupt message in
diesem video aber auch betrieb gerade
hinten sich wieder ein
rom torkeln die haut message ist neben
broadcast yourself auch respekt
also das ist ein motto was ich mir quasi
in meinem leben immer schon sehr sehr
hoch angesetzt habe wenn man quasi netz
für jemanden ist dann bekommt man noch
nettigkeit zurück es gibt ja dieses wort
nächstenliebe als das euch was sagt es
ist habe ich mal irgendwann im
religionsunterricht beigebracht bekommen
dass man quasi nett zu den anderen sein
sondern dann kriegt man halt auch nettes
zurück und es ist halt wirklich so wenn
ihr beispielsweise wenn ihr jemand fragt
wie heißt das texture pack und kann ich
in die beschreibung gruppen also ist zum
beispiel ich hab das techniken die in
der beschreibung weil es ein spezielles
tech speck ist das für mich angefertigt
wurde
aber beispielsweise jo was ist das für
musik ist jetzt hektisch was ist das für
musik und dann schreibt jemand guckt
auch in die beschreibung du vollidiot
blabla dann denke ich mir so johanna
einfach sagen schaut vielleicht die
beschreibung alter jetzt gehts hier
gerade richtig ab die finden mich
einfach nicht die finden mich nicht
sehen mich wirklich nicht die gehen weg
er hat unheimlich brutal geschlagen wie
dumm ist erstickt unter mg darunter aber
nicht auf mich drauf alter ist das
kranke alte kinder ist wir leben noch
freut mich geil
so jedenfalls möchte ich halt dass ihr
euch gegenseitig nicht mehr beleidigt
und alter sind hier viele leute gerade
hier sind wir sind viel zu viele es in
der fantasie besitz sekunde schafft ja
niemals wir sind gerade viel zu viele
leute viel zu viel ich habe richtig
angst
irgendwer trifft nicht gleich locker
irgendwer trifft mich locker okay nur
noch ein name der mich jetzt trifft
oder wenn er mich trifft nicht wirklich
er will doch nicht weil ich ja er will
wirklich zu mir hoch kommen komm bitte
schaffen
oh mein gott
juni ist traurig man hätte das versteck
ich habe fünf leute überlebt aber ihn
nicht das schade so und das hat auch
wieder meine art das sich zum beispiel
mal eine minute lang vom thema
abschweifen das bin halt ich und ich
möchte nicht so etwas lesen wie oh
blabla voll scheiße was du machst kannst
gar nix im pvp macht doch mal diesmal
das warum kommt kein galaxy mehr macht
dort dies macht doch jeder galaxy ich
mach das worauf ich lust habe und das
ist glaube ich auch der sinn von youtube
und ich finde auch dass man das
respektieren sollte man sollte auch
jeden anderen in den kommentaren
respektieren und nette sachen zurück
schreiben das ist so eine sache die ich
auf jeden fall mal an reden wollte was
ich jetzt hier am abend aufgenommen hat
und euch morgen mittag hochladen oder
morgen nachmittag und also am 11
nachmittags habt ihr das ihr rundes
vorbei ich hab leider verloren
ich hab die letzten sekunde nicht
überleben können aber ich finde ich hab
mich ganz cool versteckt und paar coole
momente war mit dabei ja ich glaub ich
hab ich oft genug gesagt aber was dieses
video ging und was meine message ist an
euch
ich hoffe einfach dass wir das umsetzen
könnte da einige leute dass ich meine es
in der wirklich nicht alle essent gibt
total viele leute die einfach nette
sachen die kommentare schreiben
daumen hoch gehen und bewerten und netz
für jeden anderen sind und ein
unterstützen und das cool finden was man
macht und traurig ist halt einfach dass
ein paar leute das nicht 100 das
irgendwie nicht beigebracht bekommen
haben von den eltern eventuell ich weiß
nicht was das für grunde hat aber das
macht mich auf jeden fall immer traurig
wenn ich dann negative kommentare sie
oder vor allem beleidigungen möchte ich
einfach nicht deswegen wenn ihr seht es
jemand beleidigt sagte man verweist
damit auf dieses video das jetzt nicht
möchte und eventuell auch leute die in
nächster zeit also ein bisschen so jo du
weg sein
die werde ich dann auch einfach
blockieren weil die möchte ich halt
nicht die mir hier als zuschauer sind
das ist ein berechtigter grund wenn da
jemand beleidigt wird und das möchte ich
auch nicht einfach mit diesem beispiel
weil es sein letztes selber mitbekommen
habe dass jemand beleidigt wurde als
suchen sondern dann hat diese person
geschrieben meine mutter ist gestorben
und ich glaube dass der person geglaubt
weil über so etwas macht man keine witze
und da habe ich mir echt einfach mal
gedanken darüber gemacht wie wir
eigentlich miteinander umgehen
das möchte ich nicht und das ist quasi
sinn dieses videos tut mir leid sich
wieder total ausgeschrieben ich wollte
dieses video kürzer halten weil das
letzte schon 19 minuten 30 gehen wir das
geht jetzt auch schon 16 minuten 30 aber
ich mal als einfach mal schluss ich
hoffe es hat euch trotzdem gefallen
bittet zeigt das video euren freunden
und es ist quasi der grund warum ich
youtube mache das broadcast yourself das
ist meine sache ich habe noch drei und
ich würde sagen es euch gefallen hat
wirklich gefallen da zeigt man mit einer
bewertung und schreiten eventuell in die
kommentare was eva dem ganzen thema
haltet und dann sehen wir uns heute
abend bei ablaufplan bike exif minecraft
35 wieder